>>Steve: We're very lucky to have Dr. Robert
Grudin here, who a few months ago finished
off a book called "Design and Truth," which,
if you haven't read it, there are order forms,
I think, on the way in. It's an excellent
book; I've read it myself. He's an accomplished
author. I'm gonna read a few things about
his biography and then we'll let Robert begin
with his reading. Robert graduated from Harvard
and received a Ph.D. in comparative lit from
the University of California at Berkeley where
he now lives. He's a Professor Emeritus in
English at the University of Oregon. Professor
Grudin's literary explorations have taken
him through a variety of literary genres,
from an encyclopedic article to Internet journalism.
He's been credited with major contributions
to five different publishing fields. Throughout
his career, he's pursued the study of liberty;
it's genesis in the mind and its implications
in the real world. His work has been widely
reviewed and his many public appearances include
lectures to professional societies in the
science, technology, business, design, government,
medicine, education, political science and
creative writing. He was a Guggenheim Fellow
in 1992 and 1993. And as I said, he's here
to talk today about his book, "Design and
Truth." At Google, we think a lot about design
and so Roberts' gonna take us back to the
roots of that idea and help us explore a bit
further. Roberts' actually also a personal
friend of mine. His son Nick and I went to
graduate school together. This weekend, Robert
saw his older son get married and for the
first time saw his first grandchild, so it's
an exciting trip out here to New York and
we're glad to have him here with us today
at Google. Robert, thank you.
[applause]
>>Robert: Thanks a lot, Steve and thank you
Google and Jay Clugston for bringing me here.
Just as a word of caution, the marriage and
the first grandchild were two different sons.
[laughter]
I've got three brief episodes to share with
you today. One of, one of them is a blog that
I did about the book and then there are two
from the book. And then I hope we'll have
time for Q&A. And the reason I chose these
three is that they are all, in a sense, unfamiliar
aspects of design. Until I started writing
this book, I thought of design as a -- I wasn't
a professional designer-- I thought of design
as a profession and I also thought of it as
an art. When I started writing this book,
I decided that design was also a philosophy;
a way of living. And that's what moti-, motivated
me through the course of my composition and
does so now. I'm now going to take off my
hat. And the reason for this hat today, is
not the blinding sun, but that this hat has
some relevance to what I'm going to talk to
you about today. And it is a Polo Ralph Lauren
and they're not paying me.
[laughter]
So, first is the blog and you can find this
on Powell's Blogs by Googling my name and,
and any big noun that I might use--
[Robert laughs]
in the course of writing this.
[reads]
"Recently, I read a blog by a writer who was
in the course of a book tour."
I, those are the most boring blogs you can
possibly read, by the way. I went to this
place and gave a talk and then I went to this
next place and well, anyway.
"It brought to mind the mini tour I'm about
to make and a few earlier ones, which range
from the hilarious to the humiliating. And
it also reminded me that the only menu item
you can order with any confidence in all 50
states is ribs. Try something else in all
50 states. Writers in general are nesting
wildlife, and as one of them, the most edifying
book tour I can think of is the long series
of nests that, over the years, I have built
for the silent performances of my task. As
I sit in this kind of crow's nest that I've
set up in the Berkeley Hills, where I live
now,--"
Where are you?
"Glancing now and then at the wall of rain
coming in from the bay, I think back on 10
or so earlier nesting attempts. The most exotic
is on Maui: a large room, windowed and screened
on three sides, where I sometimes sit at an
oak desk, writing away to the tune of screeching
francolins--they're one of the worlds loudest
birds-- eloquent sparrows, confiding doves,
the occasional thump of a falling avocado,
which at my house get up to two pounds apiece,
and the more or less constant ground bass
of gas-powered leaf-blowers from the neighbors'
yards.
But the two writer's nests that are most vivid
in memory are the following: There is the
academic jungle I set up in my University
of Oregon office when I was doing research
on a long article."
And I had been assigned to write an article
on the history of humanism. Now, I did not
know the history of humanism and why the board
at the Britannica set me up to do it was that
the little bit of humanism that I knew impressed
them. There's no, I also thought back, there
was no scholar I knew, living or dead, who
knew the full history of humanism. So, I had
a lot of studying to do. And I set up my,
my writer's studio in my office, my office
was nine by fifteen feet, in the following
way: You'll have to think back, perhaps, at
the fabric picture hooks. You would have to
lick them. Do they still have those around?
Anyway, you had to lick them until you almost
got sick to your stomach and then hold them
and press them against the wall. I set these
up on the ceiling and then, as I see from
the audience, most of you will have to look
back and imagine the early computer printers.
This was late 1984, or early 1985 and the
printers you could buy then for personal use
were all tractor-feed. Now, tractor-feed,
right now, would look very, very clumsy and
extremely commercial. It did have some advantages
and that is you could hold a whole article
or even a whole book together and if it started
falling apart, you could just drag it behind
you like some, some kind of tail. Anyway,
I, I would take my notes for this kind of
research I was doing, which was major; thousands
and thousands of words of notes. And I had
a little ladder, a step ladder, I had all
these hooks on the ceiling and I would drape
the tractor-feed over it so that I could multi-task.
That was my early ways of multi-tasking. I
could jump up from my seat and move from one
hanging tractor-feed set of notes to another
as I was typing the article in. Well, the
upshot of all this was that my office looked
like a jungle with sheets of tractor-feed
hanging down. And the sides of the office
were covered with books that wouldn't fit
in my already full bookcases, so I stacked
them. And fortunately, this accident didn't
happen until I had almost finished the article,
but at one point when I was trying to readjust
something, two or three piles of books came
down me from the ceiling, carrying with them
a festoon of tractor-feed. And I was in this
pile of books and tractor-feed on the floor
and unfortunately, I had, I had a guest at
the time so I had to wave to him, "Everything's
ok," out of the pile. That's one way an author,
at one point in time, designs his own nest.
Ok, I don't have to read from this thing anymore.
The second really dramatic thing had happened
a few years before, and that was that I was
on a sabbatical to, to write a book. And it
ended up being my book on time, which is just
a bunch of meditations. And we were forced
from our, our splendid house in Spain back
to Carmel Valley, California, where we had
a wonderful, we had a medical emergency, we
had, everything worked out ok. But we had
a wonderful invitation to come to Carmel that
had support from many, many friends on both
sides of, of the continent. Found a little
house in Carmel and the only place I could
write in this house was in an al-, a kind
of alcove. It would've been the size of a
small walk-in closet, except that it had a
window. And I could just barely fit in. There
was a table there and I had a pen and a notebook.
And it was perfect for me. I didn't feel the
claustrophobia that I do now when I get into
a room that small. I felt that I was completely
at home because I was so fascinated by the
book that I was writing, that the book had
become, in a sense, my house. Now, just think
about that. Think of a, of a project that
you have, an on-going project, that is so
absorbing that it, in a sense, becomes your
physical world. Another way I could put it,
and this is really specific to my book, is
that it was a house of time. When you are
on a long, long project and you're sort of
in charge, or you have a major responsibility
in it the way every member of a team should,
in a well working team, it becomes your own.
It becomes something that you enter. It becomes
a private room, or maybe a dialogic room that
you realize you can enter again and again
and you can call that a house of time.
And it's an interesting way of, of looking
at things that you do. Ok, if there's Q&A
on that, save it for the end because I'm not
sure how long the next section is going to
take. The next section has to do with building
and restoring furniture. And designing and
building furniture, very simple furniture,
is the only design work, aside from writing,
that I've ever done in my life. And now I'm
going to take you even farther back in time
to the middle 1970s when my wife and I and
our growing family were working in Eugene,
Oregon. This is a section called The Baker's
Table.
[reads from book]
"I have a theory about social class that goes
like this: No matter how much money you make,
you are upper class if you spend less than
you earn, and you are lower class if you spend
more than you earn. And if you spend exactly
what you earn, give or take a hundred bucks
or so a month, then you are anxious class.
"My wife and I belonged to the anxious class
when we were bringing up our kids. We worked
hard and spent our monthly checks. The mortgage
got paid, and bread was on the table. A pre-owned
car was always parked on the steep driveway
of our hillside house, presumably ready to
head for campus or take the kids to soccer.
But ideas like buying a new car or taking
a hotel vacation were simply out of the question.
"Buying decent furniture was also well beyond
our means. But lumber was cheap, so I started
building tables."
And the way to start building your own stuff,
of course, is not an apartment unless you
have a loft. You need a little studio; you
need a workbench. As it turned out, I found
a Xerox of a design for a workbench that a
friend gave me from Mechanics Illustrated.
So, I was able to build a workbench simply
out of used two by fours. So, I got this workbench.
I had a tiny, tiny basement that Nick and
Nisha remember well, and I started decorating
it with tennis posters. I put a vice; I bought
a really heavy vice and put it on the workbench.
And that's the very first thing to do if you're
building anything, is to get yourself a vice
because it's like having a friend help you
and I got some simple power tools and started
building stuff.
[continues reading]
"I designed an oak baby-changing table."
I'm not sure anyone else has ever designed
a baby-changing table. Mine would not have
worked because it didn't have any means of
restraining a baby rolling off the top. So
it was never used as a baby-changing table,
but nonetheless, it looked pretty good I must
say. It's all oak.
[continues reading]
"I designed a coffee table, that's something
that we still have and an end table and had
them assembled by the experts at a local wood
shop. These were too hard to do at home because
they, because they required diagonal cuts
and I didn't have that machine.
"Have I since become a famous furniture designer
with merchandise for sale at Skymall.com?
Not quite. But these tables taught me something.
I realized that by designing them I had turned
impoverishment into enterprise. I had transcended
my own inhibiting academic world and briefly
explored the material presences of daily life.
I had freed my eyes and hands to converse
with a varieties of shape and substance. I
had engaged my little world and changed it."
And that's what you do when you design and
build something, or have it built. Ever so
slightly, you change the world.
"For these reasons, there is something special
for me about the practice of design.
"My tables brightened up the living room and
had a generally civilizing influence on the
house. But we still had no dining table, and
at a dining table I drew the line. My design
talents did not extend to the gracious and
the festive."
By the way, in case any of you are interested,
I can now design a dining table.
[laughter]
For a very modest price of a few thousand
bucks and in case any of you want one, just
get in touch. Very unusual design, I'll tell
you, but quite practical.
"That’s where Bill and Duffy Baker came
in. They lived very near us in a big red house
and they had a, they had a big great barn
behind it. They owned a few retail businesses
in the campus village, including Duffy’s,
the saloon of choice for fraternities and
varsity athletes. Bill had a thing about furniture.
His house was crowded with antiques and handmade
pieces, including a classy four-poster bed.
His barn was full of old stuff in the various
stages, in various stages of restoration or
decay.
"A gala garage sale at the Baker barn in the
late 1970s coincided, as it happened, with
my peaking anxious-class frustration and the
semiannual lust to start making mischief with
a piece of wood. When I told Bill that I needed
a good dining table but could not pay much
for it, he said, “Bob, I’ve got just the
thing for you!” and he led me back into
the darkly stacked reaches of the Baker Barn,
on the way trying to sell me his spare four-poster
bed, which was this enormous thing. A ray
of sunlight in back caught the object of Bill’s
search, and soon I stood looking at the massive
oak table that would become, more than I thought
possible for an inanimate object, our family
icon for the next quarter-century."
And this is the table that still sits, I've
had to redo it twice now, but it still sits
in our dining room in Berkeley. By the way,
the table was built in around 1900, in a factory
in Fon du Lac. Where is Fon du Lac, Wisconsin
or Michigan? Wisconsin. Where the furniture
building at that part, at that part of American
history, a large part of the furniture building
was done in Fon du Lac.
[continues reading]
"The table, the table was a daunting prospect.
Most of the original finish was missing, exposing
wood that was alternately dried out or stained;
patches of foggy shellac still clung to other
areas. The five spiral-turned heavy legs--the
middle one was to hold up extra leaves for
the middle of the table-- looked solid enough
but would require hours of cleaning up and
staining. There were no extra leaves, and
one of the dowels, which was supposed to slide
into holes as the table was closed, was broken
off. But worst of all was the veneer top.
Thumbnail-sized bits were missing altogether.
Large areas of veneer, frayed at the edges
and completely desiccated, had parted from
the surface and curled inches into the air,
as though in defiance of anyone brash enough
to attempt a repair."
Ju-just imagine looking at that if you didn't
know anything about furniture restoration.
[continues reading]
"I said to Bill that it looked like a tough
fix.
“Piece of cake, Bob. I’ll talk you through
it,” he said, taking my hundred dollars.
"For the next two months the table stood in
my garage, getting attention. After much advice
from Bill, and my friend Bill Rockett, and
others, I turned to the job of compelling
the rampant veneer to sit down where it belonged.
I moisturized the ancient sheet of wood, very,
very thin, until it was pliant but not soaked.
Then I wiped off the liquid residue and pressed
the veneer down in place on a bed of glue.
I stabilized it with plywood, braced the job
with a large cinder block, and left it overnight.
This worked."
It wasn't curling up anymore. It was lying
flat the way it had been when it was built
at Fon du Lac all those years before.
[reads]
"When I removed the block and plywood the
next morning, the thing in the garage looked
like a table again.
"That afternoon I picked up a small package
of oak veneer and an Exacto knife at the Planing
Mill, lined up grain with grain, and cut tiny
pieces in the shape of each damaged portion
of the surface. Once in place, these were
also glued and braced.
"Over the next few weekends, cutting a dowel,
bleaching stains, removing old varnish, sanding,
applying red oak finish, sanding again, finishing,
sanding, finishing, I completed the restoration.
No boredom in that job. Often at work I was
suffused with a quiet joy. The table was becoming
a thing of beauty. I was bringing it back
to myself."
So here in the simple job of restoration,
you have a new relationship to design because
you're restoring the design of something that
was past. You're bringing back the past. And
with all of that in mind, I'd like to recommend
to you Eric Sloane's marvelous series of books
on antique wood, furniture, barns and tools,
which he illustrated himself and that's Sloane
with an "E" on the end. He wrote some of my
favorite books that I'm always re-read-, looking
for to re-read.
[reads]
"Not that it wasn’t bringing things back
to me. Restoring beautiful and useful things
of the past, particularly items of family
use, is about as close as we can get to restoring
the past itself. The feedback is little short
of spiritual. As I lavished care on the table
I was taken back into the world of my earliest
memories, when, in my grandparents’ dining
room on Hewes Street in Brooklyn, my head
had gained enough altitude for me to notice
that the big cherry-wood dining table was
covered with a layer of glass. Occasionally
this glass was lifted to allow for the insertion
of some new piece of national history, clipped
from a morning paper, the last of which was
the shocking notice, complete with photograph,
that President Roosevelt had died suddenly
in Warm Springs, Georgia, on April 12, 1945.
"It was at this glass-covered table, my legs
dangling from the seat of a claw-foot chair,
that I first took note of design and invention,
when my grandfather Julius Carlson announced
to me, in his high-pitched monotone, that
he had invented the adjustable cap."
So, I found this in a park in Berkeley about
a month ago, and I kept it, of course. And
it got lost at the wedding, but it was found
for me by a faithful son. And this is a version
of the adjustable cap of which Julius Carlson,
between 1921 and 1929, took out four patents.
Some of them look rather like this, not exactly,
and others are very different, but Julius
spent almost the whole of his 91 year life
fighting for the funds that came from those
patents and I think, not getting a cent out
of it. And that all has to do with the age
old conflict between the man or woman who's
hired to invent or design and gets, actually
gets the patent and the company, who has contracted
him and is paying him to do the designing.
[reads]
"What finally became of my grandfather’s
glass-topped cherry-wood table? As I stroked
on a second coat of shellac, I supposed that
I could track it down, but to what good? Restoring
my own table had brought me to see it with
the eyes of the past, as only a child can
see it, and now that image would be mine forever.
"A few days later, when the finish had cured
out, we carried Bill Baker’s table out of
the garage and set it down in the dining area,
which looked east toward the kitchen counter
and west toward a stand of Douglas fir. This
was in the hills of Oregon. It was splendid.
It completed the house as a family domain.
As it stood in that spot for the next twenty-five
years offering food and cheer as three kids
grew up and three cycles of dogs, stretched
out on a nearby carpet, listened to our friendly
chatter as soothing music or were troubled
by sudden stridencies."
I remember lots of kids banging their heads
on that table.
[reads]
"In my journal I describe a scene from the
mid-1980s, when Ted, our youngest, was four
years old and sitting at the oak table. This
is April 23rd, 1987: Troubles with Anthony
and Nicholas vanished in the magic of the
15th and Onyx parting; that's where I dropped
them off. But Ted opened a new canto by refusing
to go to his daycare. As he put it, “Boring.”
I dragged him there via indirect routes, including
an elevator. I bet he’s right. At his frenetic
pace of growth, he has outgrown himself and
needs some new challenge. After squabble number
one this morning, he asked me over the Cream
of Wheat, quote, “What is the future? Can
I see it?” Told, I told him only his mind
could see it, that he closed his eyes, had
to close his eyes. So he did, and I began
trying to drum up Anthony as a big man, Nick
as a big man, Teddy as paterfamilias with
kids and beloved wife.
"In those days the oak table, situated as
it was at the hub of our indoor activities,
had become the center and symbol of family
communication and sharing. It attracted and
hosted the disorderly Grudin version of the
tea ceremony. Its broad square surface and
rich brown texture created a human space that
was always inviting, always available. Its
waterproof skin accommodated hot cups and
chilled glasses a lot, alike. Its ample center
almost cried out for a turkey or birthday
cake or major salad bowl. It certainly was
in part the inspiration for the scores of
richly glazed cups, plates, and bowls that
my wife, and soon Nick, too, turned out on
the potter’s wheel on the deck and fired
at a local kiln. It faithfully fulfilled the
purpose of all dining-room furniture: facilitating
and enriching human dialogue."
I'm sorry I can't go on more with that section,
which I must say, gets rather sentimental.
But there you have an idea that I think some
designers have forgotten and that is the idea
that a piece of furniture that actually becomes
a member of the family. And that is truly
dialogic in terms of what it provides for
the family. So, I'll do one more quick section
and then we'll do a Q of A. I'm now going
to bring you up to September 2001, and 9/11.
I've got two chapters of this book about 9/11.
One of them is a rather complicated revisionist
history of the World Trade Center from beginning
to end. And the other one has to do with the
psychiatric conference. Every year for the
last 20 years, my wife Nisha and I--Nisha
is a-a-a scholar with a talent for doing drama,
or at least talking about it. We've been invited
to a big psychiatric conference to talk about
the plays that are put on at Ashland. And
this conference was going to be on, I think,
start on the 14th, had already cancelled our
airline tickets and we were going to drive
down. But I'll introduce this because this
is actually a chapter about psychological
design that occurs in many different ways.
[reads]
"How do we manage the private thoughts and
pent-up emotions that are the inevitable legacy
of our personal experiences? To some extent,
we can regulate our private knowledge consciously;
the way trainers control and train a dog."
Like, you're at a counter and you're mad at
a server or, or someone who's selling you
a ticket and should be selling you the ticket
and is doing something else. And you get angry,
but you control it.
"But our inner energies are so volatile that
conscious control inevitably proves inadequate.
We can also try acting out our feelings, but
expressing them can verge on the antisocial
and the chaotic. Our private knowledge is
the resident spirit alive within us, inalienable
and unquiet."
And so, here were a bunch of psychiatrists
trying to manage their own private knowledge.
[reads]
"On the morning of Saturday, September 15th,
2001, I sat in a committee room in Ashland,
Oregon, with a group of about 20 psychiatrists.
We were, we're all in various stages of recovery
from the events of 9/11, and they had asked
me to join them in a kind of group therapy
session."
There were about two hundred psychiatrists
at the meeting. Twenty of them were so upset,
well, I'm sure there were a number so, so
upset that they couldn't do anything, but
twenty were so upset that they got together
and decided to do group therapy and they asked
me along.
[reads]
"My role at the convention where the doctors
came annually was to lecture on Shakespeare
and not terrorism. How could I calm others
when I was myself upset? What could I possibly
say about trauma to twenty traumatized psychiatrists?"
And I'll summarize the next section; that's
where Shakespeare came in. See, there are
various sta-, events you can't stage, especially
on Shakespearean stage. You can do them in
the movies, but you can't put them on a stage.
And one of them comes from Hamlet and that
is, the beautiful young noblewoman, Ophelia,
going mad and drowning herself in a stream.
Shakespeare couldn't do that at the time on
stage, so he had someone describe it. And
this is Queen Gertrude describing it:
"There is a willow grows aslant the brook,
That shows his hoar leaves in the glassy stream;
There with fantastic garlands did she come.
Of crow-flowers, nettles, daisies, and long
purples,
That liberal shepherds give a grosser name,
But our cold maids do dead men's fingers call
them."
The distraught girl comes down to the stream;
she lies down or falls into it. She floats
away down the stream, slowly drowning. Notice
the way Shakespeare handles the precise details.
"Crow-flowers, nettles, daisies, and long
purples."
He's doing that to project the event into
the audience's consciousness, but he's also
doing something else. He's doing what I call
"The Death Story." And it's a story that we
all have to know whenever we hear about the
death of someone we care about.
[reads]
"But it also occurred to me that the death
narrative was more than just a stage tactic.
It was a cross-cultural folk tradition, affecting
us all and born of a universal psychological
necessity. Whenever we hear that somebody
important to us has died, we want to know
about every possible detail, and whenever
we are controlled, sorry, whenever we are
in control of the details, we feel obliged
to pass them on to someone else who cares.
The death narrative offers a kind of relief.
It cannot curtail our mourning, but it can
bring an otherwise intolerable truth into
the realm of day-to-day reality.
"How did all of this relate to the psychiatrists
of 9/11? That Saturday, when my turn came
to speak, I spoke to them about narrative
as a means of organizing reality. I put it
to them that the first step in healing after
a traumatic event is to construct a narrative
that places the event within a rational context.
A narrative allows the mind to couch the traumatic
event in knowable terms; a narrative stabilizes
an injured mind much in the way a splint stabilizes
a damaged limb. With this in mind, I suggested
that they all find out as much as they could
about 9/11 and construct narrative of their
own."
So, just to go into that, into a little more
detail, I had learned about the trauma narrative
from Shakespeare; that was the first thing.
He had one reason for recounting a traumatic
narrative, but I saw that he was accessing
an old, old folk tradition and if you go back
to this yourself and you've heard about the
death of a loved one, someone will, will feel
compelled to tell you every detail that she
or he knows. And you will feel compelled to
listen to the details because that person,
until that moment, has been alive to you.
And you can't just rip that person out of
your consciousness. You need a narrative.
In the same way, it is theorized. A traumatized
person, who, say, has been attacked, even
if it's long ago, can be encouraged to form
a narrative of that attack; of its reasons
and of its details. The narrative, again,
this is the theory, the narrative has the
effect of stabilizing the damaged part of
the brain so that the rest of healing can
begin. And the funny thing is, that most of
us re-, that a lot of us are so traumatized
that we try to suppress or conceal that narrative
from ourselves. And I can assure you that
doing that keeps the pain alive rather than
heals it. Anyway, when I, I had had this idea
completely on my own, thanks to Shakespeare,
so when I got home I found out what was the
most famous book on the subject. In case you're
interested, it probably is this most, still
the most famous book, it's called, "Trauma
and Recovery," by Judith Herman of Harvard
University. And I was incredibly relieved
when Judith Herman, I opened the book, I looked
up a narrative, she said the exact same thing
I had. Boy, am I smart.
[Robert laughs]
Herman has gotten into a lot of trouble, by
the way, by taking people back into their
early traumatic days and finding some scapegoat;
"Daddy spanked me that day and I've never
been the same since. I hurt for a long time,
I'm hurting now." So, there are a lot of anguished
parents who are very angry at Judith Herman,
but on the other hand, I consider most of
her ideas in that book extremely solid and
I support them. This chapter, by the way,
goes through a number of other ways in which
the mind unconsciously designs things that
it needs.
There is the dream, for example. There's also
the memory. And there's also what we call
subjectivity and that's when we have just
a very few piece of evidence and our mind
unconsciously creates a line between those
dots. You have a piece of evidence that someone
was murdered and another piece of evidence
that someone was very mad at her and saying
bad things; those are two dots and like some
detective you connect the two dots. Well,
maybe it was that person who murdered the
other person. Now, that's subjective, that's
how, that can become a hypothesis for a journalist
or a detective. It could be right or it could
be wrong, but it's a kind of unconscious instantaneous
design that we do. I'll give you a couple
of examples of design in memories and one
example is from Gen, President Woodrow Wilson.
He always felt that his first memory was of
a man riding up to his house in the Southeast,
jumping off his horse, and telling his dad
that the Civil War had begun. This would've
been 1861; Wilson would've been just beyond
a toddler, maybe five years, seven years old.
Now, that might have been his earliest retained
memory, but I doubt it. And the reason I doubt
it is because Woodrow Wilson, who brought
us into the next Great War so many years later,
so his mind was unconsciously choosing the
memory that most accorded with a great act
of his life. There's another one I can't help
telling you and with that I'm, I'm going to
conclude. And that is that I knew a guy once,
very briefly, whose name was Cornelius Bull.
B-U-L-L. And Cornelius Bull was a very well
known Middle Eastern han, so to speak. He
was one of those Americans who went forth
into a foreign country for his career and
did major things. And what it, the major things
that Neil Bull did included founding English
speaking schools in the Middle East. Now,
Neil Bull had control of the invitations to
a fairly prestigious speaking engagement that
went on every year, was founded by some big
construction, construction firm in Istanbul.
So I was brought out to Istanbul by Neil,
who was a character if you have ever met one.
And I gave a talk about the origins of creativity.
I had just written a book about creativity,
"The Origins of Creativity," sometimes having
to do with childhood experience. And my talk
was simultaneously translated to a couple
of hundred people who couldn't speak English.
It was translated almost simultaneously into
Turkish. It was a great, big, long room and
the room was so poorly designed that I couldn't
keep my, my attention on my speech almost.
I was thinking about how a room could be a
public room could be that badly designed.
But anyway, as soon as I could, I asked for
Q&A and what I asked for was for people to
share their ex-, their first memories with
me. So, Neil Bull's hand went up first and
that, at that time he was a man in his middle
60s. He said, "Oh, sixty years ago my father
took me to the zoo and we walked around looking
at animals. I had a wonderful view. And he,
because I was sitting on my father's shoulders.
He was holding me by the legs and he took
me to the elephant pen. There was this great
elephant there. It came up to see us; it stuck
up its trunk to get a peanut." So, there's
this huge trunk coming up at this little kid.
"My father handed me up a peanut to give to
the elephant and I reached out my little arm,
but just at the moment, when I was about to
put it in the elephants snout just as my father
told me to do, there was this snout right
in front of me. I froze. I pulled my arm back
and the moment I did that the elephant raised
its snout and batted me on the head." That
was his earliest memory. Well, Neil Bull was
one of the braver guys I've met and for him
to tell this early memory about his own early
trauma at the hands, or snout, of an elephant,
it was just too much like Neil Bull. I'm sure
that wasn't his earliest memory, but it's
the most amusing earliest memory I've ever
heard. In any case, the mind builds. When
the mind goes back to memories, it does some
designing. It does some building because what
it has to put together again is little dots
of data that it retains. Same thing happens
when you wake up from a dream. Generally,
you have little dots of data that, you're
lying in bed and you're thinking, "I've gotta
remember this dream." And so your mind is
unconsciously putting it together into a story.
I'm afraid that's all the time I have to talk
and I'd love to field a couple of questions
from you. Steve.
>>Steve: Yeah, I'm sorry, the, the central
or the thesis of the book is that the [inaudible]
on YouTube.
[Robert laughs]
The book is design is truth and that good
design tells the truth, bad design tell a
lie and that actually usually has to do with
the abuse of power, and I wonder if, can you
give us an example of maybe from a book or
elsewhere, design that told a lie and how
that reflected the abuse of power in one way
or another?
>>Robert: I, I believe I can think of one
and that brings me back to my other 9/11 story.
You see, when they were building the World
Trade Center it was a huge project, as you
all know. And it was originally, it was originally
conceived because of money and it was also
built, in a sense, that it would earn enormous
amounts of money. It was conceived because
David Rockefeller, who was a big deal banker,
got the idea that he could revivify commerce
in Lower Manhattan by building a trade center;
something that would simply draw in a lot
of traffic. It wasn't for 20 years that they
started the competition in which the architects
were chosen. Yamasaki was a good and very
successful architect. He was also Japanese-American.
And to my mind, he was never fully sure of
his American identity and one of the things
he did, or designed for himself in his own
mind to affirm his own identity, was to become
a kind of citizen of the world; an Internationalist.
Anyway, he had his firm do at least a hundred
models of the World Trade Center and they
were some pretty good stuff. He ended up with
a complex that would fill the available acreage
with an 80-story skyscraper and a number of
other large buildings around it. Now, if you
look south at Lower Manhattan, you'll see
three or four buildings, some of them from
the early 30s, that go up 70, 60, 70, 80 stories.
An 80-story skyscraper might have added very
nicely to the profile of lower New York. But
the Port Authority, even though they had already
chosen Yamasaki, weren't satisfied with 80
stories. What they wanted was something like
ten million square feet of office space in
two buildings. And I, I don't know how many
of you remember the World Trade Center; its
1350 feet tall, 110 stories. Every story in
each of those two buildings was an acre; two
hundred by two hundred. That's why the buildings
looked so, in a sense, nightmarish because
they were not only very tall, but they were
very, very thick. They were very wide on every
side. Now, what that means is that the majority
of people, who are working on any given floor,
are on average of what would it be? Seventy-five
feet, sixty feet away from the nearest window.
On top of that, Yamasaki, who himself had
acrophobia, made the windows so small that
you couldn't even notice the windows from
a distance. As I say in the book, "The World
Trade Center, which had the world's best view,
was legally blind itself." Yamasaki did, had,
what he had to do was make an uncomfortable
compromise with his clients and he created
a set of buildings, which in the end, told
a lie. And here is the lie: If you look at
a building like the Chrysler Building or the
old RCA building or the Liebert Building,
you're looking at a concept that was humanistically
designed. It was designed to give the individual
a sense that even though he was working in
a very large building, there was something
about that building that justified the work.
There something beautiful, there was something
human, there was something that gave vent
to the individual's aspirations. With the
World Trade Center, Yamasaki was forced to
go too far. The World Trade Center was not,
in a sense, justifying. It didn't justify
the individual. It belittled the individual
in the same sense that it belittled the other
skyscrapers. As I put it in the book, "It
stood out in the vernacular of Lower Manhattan
like a pair of hurled expletives." Expletives
not deleted until the end, of course. Yamasaki's
story goes on because there were, there were
other lies in the course of the development
of the building. New York code required six
escape routes for buildings of that size.
The Port Authority cut them to three. The
three escape routes were intertwined all the
way up to the top of the building; these were
the staircases. Had there been six escape
routes, you would've probably had, now, I
want each of you to become an architect, you
probably would've had one at each of the four
corners of each building and then two intertwined
down the middle. That's the logical approach.
If that had happened, there would've been
at least a couple of escape routes available
to the people above the crash zones, when
the crash zones, crash occurred. But instead,
the Port Authority limited them to three and
they were wound down the middle of the building.
As it turned out, after the crashes, there
was only one open escape route, it was only
partly open and only 17 people escaped down
it. Everyone else above the crash zone died.
There's another lie attached to it and this
is really amazing; most people feel chills
up their spines when they hear this one. Yamasaki
had done major work with the bin Laden family,
so that when Osama bin Laden was a little
boy in the 1960s, he clearly, we have no evidence
on this because the Yamasaki family and his
firm have shut up tight about it, but the
probability is that he, as a child, got to
know that Yamasaki was rebuilding Saudi America
along western lines. And what Yamasaki loved
to do, was he loved to take Islamic patterns
and mix them with modern architectural design.
So, it, from my perspective, and it must share
with you, that I'm designing this story myself;
Yamasaki became a kind of Darth Vader for
young bin Laden. bin Laden studied architecture
and engineering in Jeddah and it was during
his own restoration of some sacred Islamic
sites that he underwent his conversion to
Fundamental Islam. So just imagine the complex
relationship between Osama bin Laden and the
World Trade Center, and you're imagining a
lot. And one more point, and this is how I
started writing the entire article, I saw,
I saw photographs, those unforgettable photographs
of the fallen buildings with a metal trace
work still going up four stories, and it suddenly
occurred to me: those were Islamic arches.
Some people call them Persian arches because
Persia influenced early Islamic art. And it
turned out that again, I was lucky. My conception
was justified by the architectural experts
and also by Yamasaki's own bio-, autobiography.
He had deliberately built Islamic sacred language
into the formation of the square, the shape
of the buildings, and the Islamic trace work
going down it. Now, I'll tell you from the
research I've done into Islam that is a no-no.
You don't quote Islamic sacred imagery in
any way that would demean it, whether you're
putting it in a song or in a novel the way
Salman Rushdie did, or in architecture. It's
blasphemy. I don't think Yamasaki knew that,
but what he was trying to do, because he was
Yamasaki, is he was trying to again, in my
opinion; he was trying to justify his own
originality as an architect and as a human
being in the face of an embarrassing compromise
that he had had to make with the World Trade
Center. So there is design and as, it turned
into another lie when he, in his autobiography,
said, "The World Trade Center is a testament
to the common man." It, it justifies his existence,
etc. Lie, lie, lie, so far as I was concerned
and that's how I wrote it down. Thank you
very much, we ended a bit late. Thank you.
[applause]